[Music]
[Music]
any critters in here
luke and jake here with the outdoor boys
youtube channel and we're back at the
log cabin doing some camping and more
bushcraft projects
you excited jacob
well guys it's the end of october and it
is gorgeously warm today it's like 77
degrees it's got humidity in the air
it's just really nice
but we might get some rain any minute
now it could be a sprinkle it could be a
gusher we don't know so i'm gonna try to
get stuff ready as fast i can just in
case it gets a little nasty tonight all
right first thing i'm gonna tackle today
get the fire built and get our cooking
rig set up
ah
all right got some cedar bark here okay
i've got some gorgeous pieces of fat
wood i've shaved one of them up
i'm gonna take this little bit of cedar
bark
put it right there
that way you won't have to ask
all right now i got a little fire going
i'm gonna set up my camp grill
there you go what do you think jake
this was really easy to make i just took
some electrical conduit piping i pounded
the end flat
drilled holes in it
then bent two of them about 30 degrees
connected it all with one shackle bolt
then i attached four chains to a
barbecue grill
and voila we have the ultimate campfire
grill
just got a little s hook right up here
and i got plenty of chain so i can raise
or lower the grill depending on what the
fire's doing
i can just leave the thing out here or i
can fold it up lean against the tree or
stick it inside the cabin when i'm not
using it it'll work real well
well it took me an extra trip but i
hauled in
five gallons of water
and i've got myself a little wash basin
here so i can do dishes and wash hands
and all that which is going to be really
helpful because you know hygiene has
been taking a back seat these last few
trip
there you go bud
you want to eat some hot dogs
all right
looks like we got a sprinkling of rain
starting here
yeah we'll see if this gets serious or
not
there you go those are beautiful hot
dogs
you want some hot dogs bud
oh listen to that
sure is nice to be in here
oh look at this
we got water dripping down here
getting on my pad
that's no good
some of those logs are sticking out just
a little bit and catching the water
not much water is getting down the
chimney pipe anymore
that stove caps doing a good job
well now that the rain's stopped i think
it's time to move on to our second
project i'm going to try to get another
layer of tarp on top of the roof i want
it to come off the sides a little bit
better to protect from leaks
and also have a little bit of gap
between the top tarp and the bottom tarp
so you have a little bit of insulation
there
[Music]
oh son of a guy
dang it
[Applause]
[Music]
next day
when the moon isn't
i am so close to getting this roof done
but i still have about a half a dozen
grommets to tie down but we are losing
our light so i'm gonna call it for
tonight and uh i got a little boy who
wants to roast some marshmallows isn't
that right
i'm gonna hang up our
thermometer there says it's 70.
it is warm tonight you want marshmallows
yeah all right let's get marshmallows we
have three chocolate ones i'll tell you
what it's been so nice to not have to
chop firewood
oh
yeah
oh your marshmallow's on fire
like that
the last move the last moonfire there
you go bud
[Music]
well me and jacob had a great time
hanging out here by the fire but it's
starting to rain and it's getting close
to his bedtime so we're taking this
party inside
ah look at you you look all fuzzy and
warm you know with all that camo you're
kind of like john cena i can't see you
a crocodile is an opportunistic predator
wait
there is the salamander he's a pretty
one
got a real thunder lightning storm
rolled in and i'm really glad we got the
roof on
because this isn't leaking anymore
well me and jake are hanging out i just
remembered i brought a couple chunks of
virginia cured ham for uh food tomorrow
and you gotta soak that stuff for
overnight so i i'm really quick gonna
grab the pot and soak some pork
[Applause]
virginia cured hams are salted and you
can leave them out at room temperature
for like months and they they don't go
bad which makes them a great survival
food
but uh you don't want to eat them just
as is you gotta soak them and get the
salt out and rehydrate them a little bit
before you cook with them all right jake
should we go to bed now
no
well it's been a wonderful day and we've
just had a great time together but me
and jake are gonna go to bed and turn
off the camera and i'll see you guys in
the morning
oh good morning i'm tired
we stayed up way too late last night you
sleep well last night yeah and i'm sick
you have a six-pack
yeah
are you hungry jake you want some
breakfast yeah all right it's a little
cold
[Music]
we must have got at least an inch or two
of rain last night this basin filled up
pretty good
oh there's another salamander
well the roof's holding up brilliantly
all right
let's get a fire started
[Music]
you want some breakfast
here you want a muffin you got a whole
big muffin all to yourself here you can
munch on that while i get some eggs
cooked okay okay
all right
all right there we go breakfast of
champions a little bit salty a little
bit smoky not bad
well we got breakfast out of the way i'm
going to immediately start prepping
lunch i wanna make a really nice pork
stew and i'm gonna have it cook while we
work on the cabinet
i'm gonna let that pot simmer over the
fire for several hours while i work on
other things and by the time we're
hungry for lunch
should have a nice stew ready to go all
right first thing i gotta do is start
staking down this roof a little bit
better
oh we got the roof stake down really
tight which is important because when it
snows the weight of that snow will make
the roof sag inward and then the snow
and water won't drain off the roof and
it gets saggier and saggier until it
collapses if you keep the roof really
tight that snow will slide off and then
you'll have a good solid roof
i got about a one foot awning on both
sides of the cabin now that'll go a long
way to keep the rain from washing away
the mud and from seeping inside the
walls
that's boiling up nicely
next i need to build a fire in the
fireplace and test out the stovepipe
make sure it's interacting with the roof
properly and then i need to start the
chinking which is dirty work so i really
need to clear everything out of there
and make some room inside
uh
oh
stovepipes got nice and hot and it's uh
melted away any of the tarp that's too
close
the thermometer says it's 109 degrees in
here
oh it's a sweat box in there so that
little stove managed to raise the
temperature 55 degrees that's not too
bad
i'm gonna take a little tin foil and
crinkle it up and jam it around the
stove pipe it'll just improve the
insulation a little bit and help keep
the rain out
oh my goodness it's hot in there
there we go that is a lovely pork stew
i bought some of these take and bake
dinner rolls and we're gonna try uh
warming them up and cooking them over
the fire
like that
yeah
all the seasonings and brine from the
cured pork
make the broth really tasty
i didn't have to add salt or pepper or
anything
you like your food jake i got your
finished flying fish oh yeah i gobbled
it all up i was pretty hungry well i put
it off and i've put it off but it's time
to repair the chinking in this cabin
in the places where the the chinking is
really thick where there's large gaps
between the logs i shoved pure clay and
that clay shrunk and then just fell out
and so
i'm gonna try adding dry grass and that
should act kind of like rebar and make
it so that it doesn't shrink and break
up and fall out as easily so i'm gonna
grab my bucket which i broke yesterday
and uh we're gonna fill it up full of
grass and clay
let's take this back to the cabin
no we don't know
okay
hey do you want a piggyback ride up the
hill
you gotta hold on real tight
[Music]
mix
[Music]
for some of these bigger gaps the clay
just doesn't seem to cut it
so i'm using
little balls of straw and that seems to
work
well there we go got it done got all the
big holes filled up there's a few small
cracks here and there but if you poke at
them too much it knocks more clay out so
you end up doing more harm than good so
i'm gonna kind of just leave it like
this what do you think is this warm
inside yeah yeah it's very cozy
well it's been 12 months since we
started this log cabin and i'm really
pleased with how it's turned out it's
been a great project and a great way to
spend time with my boys if you guys like
this sort of video check out our camping
and adventure playlist we have over 50
videos of all of our other extreme
camping adventures and uh if you want to
see that i'll put a link in the video
description below but don't forget to
click subscribe we put out new videos
every saturday morning
if you like this video don't forget to
check out the outdoor boys youtube
channel where we have hundreds of videos
just like this and don't forget to click
subscribe so you can see other great
videos every saturday morning and hit
that bell button you'll get
notifications thanks for watching
[Music]